by the way we had that water brought in
special for you folks came from well and
Hinkley this story is really a
remarkable tale I mean I'm surprised
being me being a Californian that I had
never heard the story before
that's the pity of a story like this
isn't it yeah you would have thought
that it would
I mean being that it's PG&E right
Pacific Gas and Electric know that it
would have been kind of front page early
times yeah so you had never heard of it
either
yeah I'm extremely fast learner it's
compelling material because you have a
person who is the most unsuspecting of
heroines who also happens to be fabulous
and kind of bare than life and vivacious
and incredible and talks like a sailor
and like all these great things to play
I think I look nice
and as long as I have one ass instead of
two oh where would I like if that's
alright with you
I think we struck the right chord I mean
it was about trying to have some kind of
vital statistics that work similar to
the person I was trying to be did you
get that we tried to find a balance of
authenticity and also things that I
would have where both and still make it
seem legitimate and make it make the
sense and so I think we did that kind of
perfectly because I was sort of worried
about that
all right talked to her she said you
were fantastic good my skirts were too
long oh really
would you if you felt comfortable going
any shorter now know that that's me it's
a panting right so no I think we got off
on the wrong foot here that's all you
got lady two wrong feet and ugly shoes
it's kind of fun and there's a whole
personality that goes to wearing high
heeled shoes especially in the sand and
that is you know the scene at the
beginning of the movie where I have neck
brace on I'm going from my house to the
neighbor's house to pick up the baby you
know your wide shot of that and the
heels going across the grass and yeah
you were working but you don't even have
to work it really it kind of works
itself just nothing oh come on I'm doing
nothing what makes you think you can
just walk in there and
and what we need they're called boobs it
I'm talking about Aaron I mean was it
hard to relate to her cuz she's single
she's broke she's got three kids is that
a difficult character for you to figure
out because that's so far from your
existence first of all I think it's the
plight of most of the country and you
know certainly a plight of my youth so I
understand where the place of love that
she comes from with her children and how
important that hair taking aspect is
with the kids and I know that when I was
a kid you know you didn't get tons of
presents at Christmas because you just
couldn't afford it but you would get
that one perfect thing that made you
realize that not only was she like
putting money in the coffee can all year
but that she listened to everything that
you'd said the six months previous you
know as you were dropping your little
hints or talking about how there was a
girl in school today Jen on these guest
jeans guess is so cool and you know they
have the silk square tag it's like a
triangle and then I mean Gloria
Vanderbilt is the coolest
but the guess is a little more
affordable and you know and she just
paid attention and so I think that Erin
is like that where no matter how
difficult things are and kids always
know to a certain degree but then you
try to shield them you know and show
that things can still be fun and happy
and good and let's go out to lunch even
though she's got two nickels to rub
together for you just
mom you're not eating so it wasn't that
hard to get a grip on her except you
were carrying that baby around and you
know you looked like you knew what you
were doing there how are we doing we're
doing great I loved those kids they were
all terrific strong actors - yeah really
good yeah especially the nine-month old
one thing has nothing to do with the
other
what are those instincts come from
somewhere around the navel area I don't
know
[Music]